[Applause]
my first guest has appeared in such
films as superbad
zombieland and easy a she can currently
be seen in the new comedy friends with
benefits and her latest film
crazy stupid love opens friday
let's take a look at this clip i don't
care
i love him i really do and given the
opportunity
yes i would have his babies seriously
conan o'brien you would do conan o'brien
oh my god
ew friend to friend ew
you have so much potential and you've
resorted to fantasizing about
conan ginger junk o'brien he is funny he
looks like a carrot
please welcome emma stone so let's talk
about this movie
yeah well look you stood up for me
anyway
your character stuck up for me i mean
what's with this ew
from your friends she is a little bit of
[ __ ]
yeah and something's wrong with her
sight you know what i'm saying exactly
right she's looking at this and saying
ew
ginger junk
i didn't write it yeah i didn't write it
but um but i disagree
yeah thank you well thank you for
sticking up for me i'm gotta represent
and uh speaking of uh redheads you know
i always was in the impression that you
were a natural redhead
but you're not you are a blonde is this
right you're blonde and you decided to
go
red at some point yes how did that
happen well i was
um i was yeah i was blonde my whole life
and then i dyed my hair brown when i was
when i was 15 and then i went in for
super bad and the other girl
martha mcisac had brown hair and so judd
apatow walked in and just said make it
red
and then ever since i've been red what
kind of power does judd apatow have
and it shall be red and it just
instantly changed color
wow now have you is life different for
you as a
redheaded woman do you do people treat
you differently as a redhead
i didn't well i didn't really think
about it i just you know because i've
had it for five years but then i just
have blonde hair for spider-man yep
and i dyed it back as soon as i could to
red and i
i walked into my apartment and my friend
max was there and he said
you look a lot funnier as a redhead and
i was like really
he said yeah you've been you've seemed
like a [ __ ] for the past six months
really so there's something about red
hair that makes you seem a little
funnier you're a little funnier with red
hair i guess yeah especially if it moves
like that
now you know what's funny you have a uh
you have a i love your voice
but uh it's a very deep uh has a husky
quality to it
and i find it very very sexy oh i also
find it to be lower and more manly than
mine
have you had have people have people
thought that you were older than you
really are cause you're quite young
and and but you have the voice of
someone who's you know
lived a whole life you know what i'm
saying yeah well thank you
yeah i think that's a compliment i
really do
uh well no i mean most people just
usually think that i have a cold
or that i just woke up or people you
most taxi cab drivers call me sir
because they don't look back and
sometimes they do look back
yeah and they still call me sir on
occasion
as judd apatow said and you shall be a
man
he has that much control he has so much
power yeah
what's right how about when you're on
the phone with people you must people
must get a different idea
yeah they just yeah it's just it's it's
always um it's always a little bit of a
struggle
yeah yeah but it's been you know i'm
i've dealt with it my whole life
hey it's all working for you do not
change